it's not like i had i was a crazy kid
early on no my mom had money
it was when my mom died that i was
living out my [__] fantasies because
i had like a death wish you know i was
16 i was out there
let me tell you the first thing that
happened to me after my mom dies anybody
know what year john lennon got shot
80 december of 80 right that
when my mother died this these people
adopted me these italians
and they got me a job at a lumber yard
and i remember going there and people
like saying hey very nice to have you
and then afterwards they're like when
you talk to you we're gonna train you
and we went outside to people like
listen
you gotta steal
because the guy that had the job before
you stole like a [__]
and if you don't steal then they're
going to know upstairs so you got to
steal i'm like steal one like everything
somebody comes in to buy plywood they
pay 40 dollars you take 10 a sheet
cut the deal in the back because not the
whole everybody was stealing them
this whole [__] place everybody was
like laughing they had an old school
here i am [__] in sophomore year in
high school they had an old school
register
so if somebody came in and got something
let's say for 389 dollars
i would bring in 89 how are you paying
for this cash there was no atms then
it was your cash a check i got are you
paying for this cash i'd ring an 89
[__] dollars in pocket 300
and everybody was doing it at this place
i don't know how they [__] stayed
open
they went out of business years later
but
at that time it was like but i was like
i would come in from two to five after
high school
and this right after my mom died one day
they go mail these letters
and they would mail out like uh end of
month bills or something it was a
[__] box on top of another box
and i'd have to walk like two blocks to
the mail uh box in those days was just
i get to the post office box and i'm
putting the mail in and this [__]
letter falls out
i don't think no no i'm just putting the
[__] away i don't want to bend for it
and finally another letter falls out
like three or four of them fall out and
also my buddy comes and we're talking
[__] and i pick up the letters and i put
them back in the box
and i go back to render lumber and i'm
like what the [__] did i pick up the
letters for
i should have mailed them while i was
there i go you know what i'll mail them
on the way home
so i take the letters and i fold them i
put them in my back pocket and again i
don't [__] mail them
and i take them out there and i mail
them tomorrow finally after like a day i
go let me see what's in these [__]
things
because one letter kept going
so i open it up and it's a gas credit
card in those days you get 500 for those
just go up to somebody say you got a
[__] up car here go change it at
whatever so and
give me 500 go put 10 000 on it so i'm
like my mind's already going but there
was also two checks one for 25 five
thousand one for eighteen
thousand i put the checks in the draw
it's 19 [__] 80. i don't even think
about it
the next day i'm talking to my friends
in sophomore class and i'm telling them
dog i got these checks and he goes
talk to my brother
he works at the bank what are you
slipping
so i call him up that night he goes meet
me at nick's pizza this greek guy that
made pizza
he wasn't even italian but he made good
pizzas
except for the sicilian he leave it by
the window and the flies
would use it like as a [__] take-off
thing you know what i'm saying
so every once in a while you got a
sicilian with a fly and then [__] you're
like nick get my money back
we used to rob him too cause we
we would burglarize houses like little
things rings and [__] and bring them to
nick we got some gold gold in those days
gold is 1800 an ounce now or something
three i don't even know in those days it
was like a thousand that was a lot
so everybody was buying gold people say
you got gophers i'll buy it because i
know somebody
so nick would buy gold and he had like a
like
an apron that he would hang and he would
buy the gold from us and then put him in
the apron
and he would let it stock in so i come
three days then go nick i gotta take a
[__] let me use your bathroom
and i'd steal the gold and put it back
from my pocket i'd steal the gold back
and i go like three days later nick i
got some gold
look familiar and and he didn't [__]
around he called me the [__]
there was no [__] around there was no
ethnic [__] in those days
speak why do you do this to me
i had a buddy who had a beard he called
him the ayatollah
i had another buddy who was rich vanirie
rich [__] undertaker
he would come and buy a slice of pizza
but he would cross the street to get an
iced tea
because it was a nickel less
and nick would come onto the street and
go venerie you [__]
jew
[Laughter]
yell it like it was [__] allowed like
venery [__] you you [__] jew
one night i got [__] up in there and
puked and [__] and he said something to
me
so i threw the red pepper at him and it
was everywhere and he wouldn't allow me
in the pizza place and he kept calling
me balushi
you're going to die like belushi you do
too much
he and we used to get him to smoke pot
and [__] like we see him nick come here
with no no no no i smoke
get it come here [__] smoke this
[__]
good stuff
so nick nick was my [__] [__]
i love nick's pizza that was my
so i meet this guy up at nick's pizza
and i tell him the situation i give him
the two checks
and he says to me be here tomorrow night
at eight o'clock either i'll catch him
or i can't he goes here's the deal
if i cast these checks you keep the 25
grand and i keep the 18.
done i'm a [__] sophomore in high
school what am i gonna do with 25
[__] grand
i give them the checks and i don't even
think about it the next night at about 7
30 my phone rings
the phone's for you coach i answered
who's this it's brian
meet me at knicks and a half hour i just
hung up the [__] phone i'm like no
way i take the bus to nix and he gives
me [__] a thick bank envelope
with 50s and hundreds he goes there's 25
000. don't ever [__] repeat this
i took it home and i remember that
weekend john lennon like he died that
monday
and that weekend i had this big thing in
new york and i remember taking like a
handful of [__] money
and going to the village and going to
blee kabobs and buying all these albums
and that's the first time i seen the
blizzard of oz it was just coming out
for the first time
the ep of the first four songs mr
crowley and [__]
anyway i didn't shoplift it so there's
no story there
i paid for it cause i had the duckets
[__]
and there's more where that came from
listen to how much of a puerto rican i
was i didn't even put the money in the
bank i had in a sock drawer
and i would just take 20s or 50s out
like at night like [__] it i just need
50 to take out that lasted me like six
[__] months but what i did was with
it
i took the money and i wanted to become
a drug dealer so i want to put my money
on the street
my sophomore year so my friend nikki
took me to this place in pennsylvania
college east stroudsburg pennsylvania
and they had these kids that would make
acid and pills they were [__] mad
scientists bro you should have seen
they were 20 and they already had white
hair beards and [__]
and they would make acid and then thc
crystal and gorilla biscuits and
quaaludes and
whatever they had like so i that's how i
made a living see the economy is bad
today
because they took away the underlying
money-making situation for people
if you were broke 20 years ago you get
100 quaaludes on the arm for 200
go to the ice house to the bar you'd
sell them in one night for four dollars
even if you ate three of them you're
still clear to buck 75
you do that five nights a week that's a
thousand [__] dollars
plus your unemployment plus your mug of
[__] it all adds up at the end of the
[__] month you suck a dick it all
adds up
so people didn't need a job
you know and credit cards i was a king
of credit cards because
in the old days if it was under 50 they
wouldn't [__] swipe it
there was no swipers there was a [__]
book you think somebody's gonna sit
there for an hour
and look at a [__] book so they were
called under the limit thieves
we just went out every day and got [__]
under fifty dollars
they [__] it could be a card that was
ten years old they wouldn't give a [__]
that's why the economy is bad because
there's no lower level stealing no more
nobody can [__] make a living no more
we get a hundred hits of acid for 90
[__] dollars and sell them for three
dollars
i would sell 100 it's acid as i walked
into the high school
you just got a bunch of stupid girls
they're gonna play hooky there you go
that's 12 [__] hits at three dollars
a piece i used to get black beauties
they're like speed
i used to get a thousand for 35 hours
but i'd sell a hundred for forty dollars
are you [__] this is sophomore year i
made more money as a kid in high school
that i would do today
that's [__] sad
you could go out to the track when i was
a kid my mother died these are the
things i did this is why i didn't think
it was criminal
like you go to the track and hang out if
somebody wins a trifecta for
ten thousand dollars and they owe child
support they can't cast that ticket
you come over your social security they
gotta give you ten points of the action
i go home with a thousand [__] bucks
on the track this is how i learned this
was my mind the hustling
there was no [__] when you wake up
every day you're trained to come home
with something
you gotta come home with something this
is now that people are unemployed how
the [__] are you unemployed
you don't see nobody on the [__]
corner you know those beer trucks
you know why there's two [__]
in the beer truck
15 and 16 they pull up by themselves
they go out
you pull up with your buddy in the car
and your buddy holds you back here
[__] tight you stick your [__]
head out the window and slide that
[__]
and just start putting cases of beer in
a [__] car you drink for free and you
sell the other cases for 30 bucks kids
don't think like that
they're [__] at 7-eleven buying
five-hour energy and texting and [__]
like that
that's why there is a [__] problem in
this country because we've forgotten the
hustle
and when you're hustling you don't
[__] know somebody comes up to you
and says dog
you're not gonna believe this i got a
thousand watches i can't sell them
all i want is three dollars a watch you
get 20 a piece give them to me i didn't
give a [__]
i'd sell them door to [__] door i
played cyo basketball for a church with
a bunch of other [__] catholics
they would give us these stickers that
we had to sell for a dollar
we broke into the [__] church in the
eighth grade and took all those stickers
and sold them then give the church dick
all these stories i'm telling you that's
the one i'm worried about the most when
i go to [__] saint peter
i'm gonna go up there and go you did
great dog what do you mean i kidnapped
the dude i lit
the [__] hooker's wig on fire
you did great the only thing you [__]
up was the eighth grade when you stole
from the [__] church and you stole
those [__] stickers